Libraries, I think, can have an amazing role to play
because they are like tanks full of knowledge
so knowledge banks, if, you want,
and the thing is, though, that libraries very often
tend to be, sort of, retroactive in terms of looking back.
Maybe one could think of a library as about
producing the future.
Maybe an archive of old stuff.
It's not really about going back in time.
Maybe the archive is also
about using it about
going into the future.
And then that way, a library could
really be a time machine
through which we can look into,
well, what do we need to do
about changing things in the future.
And I guess that also means reconsidering
the, you know, the fact that libraries are very often
very stiff and inflexible, and,
you know, they need to re -
They need to reconsider how to
reach out to people
But clearly, libraries are amazing
resourceful systems,
which we just need to activate.